hello everyone and welcome to the start
of the world Fisher random Championship
or fish around the world championship
it's an event that will over the next
five days decided the fate of the World
Chess Championship in Fisher random uh
the world champion Wesley so is
defending his title and there are seven
other Challengers so four of those have
qualified through a qualification
process and four of them uh have been
decided up front you have Wesley saw the
current world Fisher random Champion
Magnus Carlson as um uh the previous
event runner-up then you have a Yani
polishi who was sort of an um uh an
invitation by fide as fide is organizing
this event it's an official video event
and also you have
um let me just check uh so I don't mess
it up yeah invited by the Icelandic
Chess Federation
[Music]
so those four were invited and then you
have the people who actually qualified
for the event Vladimir the Matthias
bluebound Hikaru Nakamura and noderbeck
Abdu satrov so they will play each other
uh two two games against each other uh
in the in the preliminaries and then
they will go into the main event so it's
uh 25 minutes per player and then you
have five uh but that's only for the
first 30 moves because this fish around
them you don't have openings so you
really need time
to focus on your moves uh then you will
get uh a nice five second increment for
every move you make and you will get an
additional five minutes I I believe
after you reach that move 30. also you
will receive 15 minutes before the
actual start of the game to analyze the
position because this is the position
for the for the first round uh there we
have it it's uh fairly similar to normal
chess like you have the the The Rook
denied at the bishop but then instead of
the queen you have the bishop then the
bishop and the queen are basically
swapped and then this rook and Knight
are swap so a few moves into the into
the game it will probably resemble uh
normal chess and the first game the one
that we are showing is a very very
interesting one you guys will enjoy it
so let's dive straight into it and uh I
don't know if I I forgot to mention
anything about
um the well as this is the first round
I'd like to mention a little bit a
little bit about the tournament but I
think we cover pretty much everything if
you guys want to know something uh just
ask and I will I will answer it so okay
Magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with Pawn to D4 it's always very very
interesting uh how the players will play
the openings because they are only
presented with the positions they will
be playing uh before uh starting the
game they have 15 minutes they have to
analyze them uh with their seconds I
believe they don't have to do it alone
and then
uh they have to figure out how to how to
approach this game so D4 and okay Magnus
decides the uh on the first move
recommended by the engine and here we
have Pawn to C5 which is definitely not
the first move recommended by the engine
but uh Vladimir wants to play Something
Something funky maybe a nice D5 a
symmetrical or E6 it would have been uh
something that the engine would
appreciate but okay this is official
random uh who cares really Pawn to D5
Magnus grabs more space in the center we
have Ponte E6 and now Ponte E4 Pawn to
C4 also possible like something
resembling a a benoni if you will and
now Queen to D6 already a a weird move
what what is Queen to D6 he is
developing the queen and already
attacking the pawn on H2 but Magnus
doesn't really care about that pawn he
just plays Knight to C3 and grabbing
this Pawn does not even win you a pawn
if you grab the pawn just Knight G3 now
threatens to win the queen so have to
start running let's say Rook to H1 Queen
has to go back and now you even pick up
the H7 Pawn so you haven't really not
won anything here so after Knight the C3
Knight the G6 and now Pawn to F4 by
Magnus
uh we have Bishop day five now uh
pinning the knight uh and queen to F2
now for those of you who are new to
visual random uh all of the rules are
the same as in regular regular chess
except the rules of castling here you
can see that the king and Rook are an E8
and G8 and normally if you had this
position you would not be able to Castle
but because the King still hasn't moved
and this Rook hasn't moved they can
actually just Castle but I will show it
to you in uh yeah very quickly for
example if white played something like
H3 here Magnus played uh Queen to F2 to
actually prepare castling then you would
have some like ecapters on the five and
a few characters on D5 black would just
Castle well the point is it doesn't
matter what the distance is between the
black king and the the black Rook you
could Castle even if the King was all
the way here and The Rook was all the
way here uh the point is after they
Castle they end up in the exact same
position they would be if you were
playing regular chess so that's uh the
the main difference so okay after Bishop
day a A5 we have Queen to F2 Magnus also
prepares the castle he captures on D5
and now we have Castles by Magnus and
now okay he's given up a pawn what can
uh Vladimir do he could capture on C3
that's definitely an option he could
capture an E4 but he wants it all he
plays Pawn to D4 he says I'm keeping the
extra Pawn I'm allowing E5 I'm allowing
the knights the E4 uh but this against
especially against someone like Magnus
this definitely sounds like trouble
because look at this Ponte E5 now okay
if you look if you've got something like
Queen to C6 then you even allow Bishop
to F3 and you don't want your queen
further harassed so Queen back to E7 and
now Knight the E4 going after that uh D6
square and also how are you stopping
just Knight G3 Knights the F5 also
coming to D6 these are things that you
should have considered before pushing
this D4 Pawn uh because even if this was
not a official random game okay let's
say black black castles now okay now
I'll add both players have Castle so now
it's basically a normal position look at
this Rook Knight and Bishop occupy
normal squares Bishop on A5 Queen on E7
so this is a position you could uh
really end up playing uh but now if you
look at it it is just a terrible
position for black the pawns on E5 and
F4 the pawn is coming to five at some
point the the Knight like we said is
coming to F5 you can never push this
Pawn uh because just the characters on
D6 uh
so it's a really really crazy stuff so
Knight H the G3 and now uh what do you
play uh also interesting uh now now you
can't even play D5 any characters as the
Knight here is protected you could play
F5 though F5 is very interesting because
now if you play e captures and F6 Alpha
G captures on F6 okay you've uh saved
yourself a little bit but now F5 and now
you either resign here or you have to
play something like D5 attack the Knight
and after captures and captures now you
play Bishop to H6 and now you resign as
black uh because there's a really not uh
not much you can do here whatever you
play even if you move the Rook just
Knight captures an E4 uh the queen can
never go here because of Queen captures
on F6 and if something like H captors on
G6 you you still don't go after the Rook
you play Knight captures on e4 right now
again yeah you are without a move here
so okay after Knight H the G3 Bush will
be back to C7 singing okay I'm not
giving you the D6 Square I'm still gonna
see see what happens with my pawns and
now Magnus just plays Knight F5 it
attacks the queen here Queen back to d8
and now we have Knight F to D6 and now
okay you have to start um capturing some
Knights here with Bishop captures Knight
captures and now Knight the C6 Magnus
plays Bishop to E2 he wants them uh
shift to the bishop into the attack
somehow uh that's a weird Arrow into the
attack somehow we have Queen to G3 by
Magnus
sorry first F6 uh challenging the
structure here but now Queen to G3 and
this is also beautiful he's sacrificing
another Pawn but if uh this Pawn is
accepted uh Vladimir would not have a
great time here then just spawn to F5
and there's really no good Square for
the Knight here whatever you play you're
just getting destroyed here doesn't
really matter even if you play Knight F4
you could even Rook captures on F4
captures captures this is just the the
disgusting to play there there's nothing
you can do the bishop can come to C4 to
D3 uh this is uh this is so bad for
black uh so okay after Queen to G3 we
have Queen to E7 uh trying to trying to
develop a little bit but now just Bishop
the C4 with check King the h8 and now
Rook the F3 Magnus announcing that there
are some very very uh sneaky moves in
the position as I'm sure you guys are
already realizing as soon as the Rook
was lifted we have Pawn to B5 trying to
give up a little bit bit of material to
develop we have Bishop to D5 and now F
characters on E5 sort of getting ready
for Pawn to F5 but maybe just maybe
there is something better in the
position so feel free to pause the video
and try to find the only move that wins
by force for Magnus while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on always looking for
that nicest move to play and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
and yes I will do it uh the in slow
motion it is Queen captures and G6 look
at this beautiful stuff here and of
course the queen cannot be accepted so
congratulations to everyone who found
that you are a true uh uh sacrificer of
valuable pieces uh because now if if the
queen is captured Rook to H3 check Queen
to H4 and now this is just Checkmate as
the bishop covers this diagonal which I
uh announced in the thumbnail so here
Rook to F6 was played okay ordana please
but maybe you're still fighting but not
really just Queen to E8 with the check
captors captures and now again there's
really not much for you to do the Rook
is hanging if you go back then the night
goes back Knight to D6 you still can't
develop any of your pieces so E4 uh this
is a final attempt by philosoph to try
and save the game but just Knight
captures on F6 by Mac Agnes e captures
on F3 we have Knight the E Knight the E4
now end upon the C4 so he does have a a
nice Pawn chain here but just Bishop to
D2 uh we have rooked the B8 and now we
have Rook to E1 and it was in this
position and move 25 that Vladimir fedos
have resigned to the game and the Magnus
Carlsen wins the first game of their
match another one will be played so uh
we'll see what happens uh in in in that
one the position will remain the same I
believe the positions only change on the
second end as we will have five days of
the of the official random World
Championship uh there will be or the
rather there should be five different
positions I don't know if they if they
mix it up for Armageddon or or if um uh
you know for tie breaks but I will keep
you guys informed but yeah very nicely
done by Magnus uh there is also another
very nice game that was played in round
one so we are going to show that one
next I'm sure you guys know which one
I'm talking about so yeah stay tuned for
that but yeah here you've just done
material there is no compensation here
it doesn't really matter what you do
it's just completely lost for black and
of course Vladimir designs but yeah very
nicely done by Magnus and like I said I
mean here you can see as soon as black
castled in in this position it doesn't
matter what type of Chess you're playing
it doesn't matter if the rules are the
same you know that you're not surviving
this against Magnus costs and doesn't
matter if it's a regular chest or
official random uh look at your I mean
look at your pieces so uh yeah we'll see
if uh Vladimir sticks to this idea of uh
of just going C5 and then E6 and then
Queen to D6 or I don't know if it was
meant to actually go after the H2 Pawn I
don't think so sort of uh just maybe an
aggressive approach but it didn't go all
that well uh so yeah uh that's the first
game hope you guys enjoyed it and uh
here uh I can even show you a nice
moment
um when uh let me just check I have it
somewhere here uh when uh Vladimir
resigned it was uh uh I saw it in the
live stream it was a really fine moment
because he sort of uh still or rather
not glanced he sort of stared into the
distance uh okay let me just check
here it is
I'm pretty sure you guys would would
enjoy seeing this one yeah look at this
so this was uh yeah there we go
all right so there you have it that uh
Magnus was sort of like staring at the
at him a little bit and he was like
looking in the distance maybe he was
just checking the scoreboard of the
other players or maybe he was just I
don't know but he was uh he he stood
still like this for a couple of seconds
and then he looked at Magnus and then he
was like yes okay I resigned uh so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it uh I would like to thank Joshua Baker
Derek Alex Williams Stephen Pryor uh
shadri subramanian and John uh shortlist
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event until
it finishes uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day